let me ask you uh
uh
sort of a big question about preference
what would you say is the best
programming language
your favorite
but also the best you've seen
throughout your career you're considered
by many to be
the greatest programmer ever i mean it's
so difficult to place that label on
anyone if but if you put it on you and
it's you so let me ask you these kind of
ridiculous questions of what's the best
band of all time but in your case what's
the best programming language everything
has all the caveats about it but so what
i use so nowadays i i do program a
reasonable amount of python for aiml
sorts of work uh that's i'm not a native
python programmer it's something i came
to very late in my career i understand
what it's good for you don't dream in
python i do not and it has some of those
things where there's some amazing stats
when you say if you just start if you
make a loop you know a triply nested
loop and start doing operations in
python you can be thousands to
potentially a million times slower than
a proper gpu tensor operation and these
are staggering numbers you know you can
be as much slower as we've almost gotten
faster in our uh you know our pace of
progress and all this other miraculous
stuff so your intuition's about
inefficiencies within the python sort of
it keeps hitting me upside the face
where it just it's gotten to the point
now i understand it's like okay you just
can't do a loop if you care about
performance in python you have to figure
out how you can reformat this into some
big vector operation or something that's
going to be done completely within a c
plus plus library but the other hand is
it's it's amazingly convenient and you
just see stuff that people are able to
cobble together by you just import a few
different things and you can do stuff
that nobody on earth could do 10 years
ago and you can do it in a little
cookbook thing that you copy pasted out
of a website so that is really great
when i'm sitting down to do what i
consider kind of serious programming
it's still in c plus plus and it's
really kind of a c flavored c plus at
that where i'm not big into the modern
uh template meta programming sorts of
things i see a lot of train wrecks
coming from some of that over
abstraction
i spent a few years really going kind of
deep into the kind of historical lisp
work um and the haskell and some of the
functional programming sides of things
and there's
there is a lot of value there in the way
you think about things and i changed a
lot of the way i write my c and c plus
plus code based on what i learned about
uh the value that comes out of not
having this random mutable state that
you kind of lose track of
because something that
many people don't really appreciate
until they've been at it for a long time
is that it's not the writing of the
program initially it's the whole
lifespan of the program and that's when
it's not necessarily just how fast you
wrote it or how fast it operates but
it's how can it bend and adapt as
situations change and then the thing
that i've really been learning in my
time at meta with the oculus and vr work
is it's also how well it hands off
between a continuous kind of revolving
door of programmers taking over
maintenance and different things and how
you get people up to speed in different
areas and there's all these other
different aspects of it so c plus plus a
good language for handover between
engineers probably not the best i and
there's some really interesting aspects
to this where in some cases languages
that are not um that are not generally
thought well of for many reasons like c
is derided pretty broadly that yes
obviously all of these security flaws
that happen with the memory and
unsafeness and
buffer overruns and the things that
you've got there but there is this
underappreciated aspect to the language
is so simple anyone can go and you know
if you know c you can generally jump in
someplace and not have to learn what
paradigms they're using because there
just aren't that many available i think
there's you know and there's some really
really well-written c code like it's i
find it great that if i'm messing around
with something in open bsd say i mean i
can be walking around in the kernel and
i'm like i understand everything that's
going on here uh it's not hard for me to
figure out what's i you know what i need
to do to
you know make whatever change that i
need to
while you can have you know more
significant languages like
it's a downside of lisp where i don't
regret the time that i spent with lisp i
i think that it i it did help you know
help my thinking about programming in
some ways
but the people that are the biggest
defenders of lisp are saying how
malleable of a language it is that if
you write a huge list program you've
basically invented your own kind of
language and structure because it's not
the primitives of the language you're
using very much it's all of the things
you've built on top of that and then a
language like racket kind of one of the
more modern lisp versions it's
essentially touted as a language for
building other languages and
i understand the value of that for a
tiny little project but the idea of that
for one of these long term supported by
lots of people kind of horrifies me
where all of those abstractions that
you're like okay you can't touch this
code till you educate yourself on all of
these things that we've built on top of
that and it was interesting to see how
uh when google made go a lot of the
criticisms of that are it's like wow
this is not a state-of-the-art language
this language is just so simple and
almost crude and you could see the
programming language people just looking
down at it but it does seem to be quite
popular as basically saying this is the
good things about c everybody can just
jump right in and use it you don't need
to restructure your brain to write good
code in it so i i wish that i had more
opportunity for doing some work
in go uh rust is the other modern
language that everybody talks about that
i'm not fit past judgement on i've done
you know a little bit beyond hello world
i wrote some like video decompression
work in rust just as an exercise but
that was a few years ago and i haven't
really used it since you know the best
programming language is the one that
works generally that you're currently
using because that's another trap is in
almost every case i've seen when people
mixed languages on a project that's a
mistake i would rather
stay just in one language so that
everybody can work across the entire
thing and we have i get meta we have a
lot of projects that use kind of react
frameworks so you've got javascript here
and then you have
c plus plus for real work and then you
may have java interfacing with some
other part of the android system and
those are all kind of horrible things
and that was
you know one thing that i
i remember talking with uh with baz at
facebook about it where like man i wish
we could have just said we're only
hiring c plus plus programmers i am and
he just thought from the from the
facebook meta perspective well we just
wouldn't be able to find enough i
you know with the thousands of
programmers they've got there it is
not necessarily a dying breed but you
can sure find a lot more java javascript
programmers
and i i kind of mentioned that to elon
one time and he was kind of
flabbergasted about that it's like well
you just you go out and you find those
programmers and you don't hire the other
programmers that don't do the languages
that you want to use but right now i
guess yeah they're using javascript on a
bunch of the spacex work for the ui side
of things when you go find ui
programmers their javascript programmers
i wonder if that's because there's a lot
of javascript programmers because i do
think
that great programmers are rare
that it's not
you know if you just look at statistics
of how many people are using different
programming languages that doesn't tell
you the story
of what the great programmers are using
and so you have to
really look at what you were speaking to
which is the fundamentals of a language
what does it encourage how does it
encourage you to think what kind of
systems does it encourage you to build
there is something about c plus plus
that has elements of creativity but
forces you to be an adult
about your programming which it expects
you to be an
expectantly and so
forced
adult
it's so it brings out people
that are willing to be creative in terms
of building large systems and coming up
with interesting solutions but at the
same time have the sort of the good
software engineering
practices that amend themselves to real
world systems
you